welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division's penultimate
episode finally showed us the origin of
the scarlet witch one of maximoff's
sokovian orphan born with the power of
bomb
stalin later amplified by an infinity
stone into
a nexus beam level god mode but most
mysterious was the
way that mind stone meet and greet
played out wanda briefly witnessed a
silhouette in the shape of her future
self as a scarlet witch
but was that what it was who exactly did
she see
what exactly did that vision mean and is
this the wanda
vision of the one division title i know
that didn't really blow your mind the
show has already done it like six times
episode eight confirmed that wanda did
not get her power solely from the mind
stone but rather
she already had a low level magic from a
young age
the stark bomb that traumatized wand and
pietro failed to detonate not because it
was defective
this is stark industries we're talking
about not hammer tech but because
wanda cast what agatha later identified
as a probability hex
these were among wanda's powers in the
early comics her magic allowed her to
alter the causal probability of events
so this would imply that wanda could
have been a witch from birth or at least
from a very young age now she was
originally a mutant in the marvel comics
the daughter of magneto later comics did
alter that history but
classically wanda and pietro have been
understood to be mutants
associated with the x-men and other
mutant groups house of m the most famous
scarlet witch comic event is very much
an x-men mutant story now before one
division came out
marvel began to drop hints in companion
literature that hydra might have
chose wand in pietro's sokovian homeland
for their mind stone experiments because
those test subjects were just naturally
more likely to survive that radiation
exposure of course we did see in the
winter soldier post-credits scene in
this one division episode that most of
those test subjects died but
wanda and pietro survived suggesting
that both could have been born with a
kind of genetic predisposition
honestly that's the best explanation for
that because pietro isn't a witch so
we're probably looking at
something genetic a mutant gene or an x
gene which kind of gives us a formula
here
mutant gene plus cosmic radiation yields
powers
interestingly we see a similar equation
with monica rambo
she was exposed to cosmic radiation with
her passes through the hex wall
but we were shown clues that her dna was
freaky before those exposures
after only two out of three of those
exposures her x-ray scans showed up as
blank and she was capable of ripping the
rover hatch door fully off its hinges
and before any of those exposures she
floored a dude in the hospital who looks
like he had at least 40 pounds on her
so yeah the same kind of equation right
some natural pre-existing
maybe genetic starting mutation plus
radiation
gives us new powers now when monica got
irradiated she heard voices from her
past her mother maria carol danvers nick
fury this is similar to other times mcu
characters have encountered infinity
stone derived radiation peter quill
while wielding the power stone saw a
vision of his mother on her deathbed
thanos saw young gamora in the soul
stone and similarly this was a deleted
scene but tony stark saw a future
version of morgan stark in the soul
realm
after he snapped but with wanda seeing
the scarlet witch in the mind stone glow
this is the first time we have seen a
character see a future version of
themselves
but since wanda maximoff is a unique
nexus being with the power to rewrite
reality
and branch out into the multiverse i
believe that what we
and wanda are seeing is not a future
version of herself
but the way monica split into alternate
selves
wanda actually saw an alternate reality
version of herself now some have
wondered if this silhouette could have
been wanda's mother irina meximoff
since in some comics wanda's mother was
a scarlet witch before her
and that irina's weird reaction to the
danger in the streets of scovia was just
because she might have wanted her and
oleg to die so that her children could
fulfill their destinies
yeah no i don't think so what a crummy
thing to do to your kids
especially when that would essentially
doom your son to death really folks to
the maximoff's civil unrest in sokovia
was sadly a routine occurrence now they
probably didn't expect it to escalate to
an air raid but really they were just
trying to distract their kids from all
that violence and chaos
like that heartbreaking irish mom
telling her kids bedtime stories as the
titanic went down
and dick van dyke closed his thumbs for
dreaming about walnuts but mama i like
dreaming about walnuts why they taste
better than taters
taters are what you're gonna get i guess
you don't need your thumbs do you
and when you adjust the levels on the
silhouette you can see that this is just
clearly elizabeth olsen's face but
with darker hair than the red hair she
has right now so we're looking at an
alternate wanda look going through these
theories and easter eggs makes me really
want to drink at the end of the day
my drink of choice lately has just been
a nice glass of wine but here's a prom i
don't know anything about wine
all the labels just have a tree on them
i probably know more about dornish wine
from game of thrones than i do about
actual non-fictional wine well lucky for
me there is bright cellars
they use a quiz to determine your taste
preferences and then they show you a
list of the top six
wines you're most likely to enjoy from
around the world they ask
easy questions like what's your favorite
type of chocolate or juice and then they
show you your best matches they educate
you about wine along the way to help you
find your new favorites
if you like your recommendations and
want to try them they'll ship them
straight to your door this is what it
looks like when it arrives then you open
it up and you got some nice wine options
in there
they sent me a pinot noir that i really
liked and it's apparently not pronounced
a peanut
no wire it was really great it was easy
to drink it had some of those nice
earthy flavors in it that went well with
a hearty take out meal because that's
all i really eat listen to me i'm
basically a sommelier now
another word i just learned now i got
six bottles total so i'm excited to try
the others and learn more about what i
like or what i don't like and you can
rate the wines that brightseller sends
you and then they use that info to
improve their recommendation algorithm
and give you better matches
just click on the link in the
description of this video and take the
quiz yourself you will receive
50 off your first six bottles when you
use our link
and thanks again to bright sellers for
sponsoring us really the weirdest thing
about wanda's mind stoned baptism isn't
just a silhouette of the scarlet witch
it's that this stone wriggled free from
loki's scepter and floated out toward
her
it chose her why did it do that when the
mind stone amplified this low-level
sorcery that wanda possesses as a child
it charged her up
in a way that now makes her a kind of
mythological goddess at least that's how
agatha described it you're supposed to
be a myth
a being capable of spontaneous creation
this is chaos magic wanda but that makes
you
a scarlet witch the scarlet witch not
just a superhero nickname but a title
a rank agatha's mother evanora's blue
magic manifested as a crown around her
head
a crown that agatha did not inherit
after draining evanor's life force
yet distinctly visible in that
silhouette even in the reflection of
wanda's eyes that's how important they
wanted this shape to be
that pointed tiara i think this means
that
the scarlet witch is a rare distinction
that has been sought after by agatha a
distinction that is really the witch of
all witches
the myth of all myths a sorceress so
powerful that she can tap into the
multiverse as a nexus being
in spawn realities where the dead can
walk once more those of you confused why
hayward was able to track vision inside
the hex when that vision wasn't based
off of the parts from the sword
headquarters it's because the vision
that wanda made in the hex
isn't an illusion or a fantasy this is a
real reality she created vibranium out
of nothing
and wanda only has that power because
her low level sorcery was amplified by
cosmic radiation
the magic of the infinity stones science
so advanced that as guardians equate it
with magic
and asgardians had witches too thor's
mother friga was a witch
so they know what they're talking about
there and the stone chose wanda because
the nexus being the scarlet witch in a
separate reality a time and space
far beyond this one tapped back into
this reality at this time in space
to make sure this stone in this moment
connected with wanda
closing the loop but instead of a time
travel way
a trans-dimensional kind of way see i
guess i see it as side to side instead
of forward and backward but i guess not
everyone has my same spatial orientation
of time travel versus time hopping or
sees the number three as green and the
number four is blue or the month of june
in the five o'clock position of a
stretched out salvador dali clock
shut up hey support this channel in my
madness by checking out one of our great
merch options at newarkstarsmerch.com
like this an unusual couple shirt i i
swear it gets washed at least once a
week
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars subscribe to
new rockstars for everything wandavision
thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you